since the start the Biden Administration
has not once urged Israel to stop its
constant attacks on Gaza until Biden
heard this at a fundraiser Wednesday
night as a rabbi I need you to call for
a ceasefire right now he responded it's
time for a pause to get the prisoners
out the administration making it clear
this is not a call for a ceasefire or
even an extended pause just to remind
when we're talking about humanitarian
pause um what we're talking about our
temporary
localized pauses in the fighting to meet
a certain goal or goals as I said get a
in get people out as he heads to Israel
Secretary of State Anthony blinkin said
he would be working with Israel to come
up with concrete steps to try and
protect civilians without giving any
details and in the midst of the ongoing
Carnage he now says he'll Focus over the
next days on what happens when this
Onslaught ends I expect you'll see a
focus there and particularly how we can
get over time two two states for two
peoples which in our judgment Remains
the best guarantor and maybe the only
guarantor of a secure Jewish and
Democratic Israel and uh Palestinians
with the state uh that they're entitled
to but there are growing questions about
the way Israel is conducting this war
and the growing civilian death toll but
at the Pentagon a complete backing of
what Israel is doing now having
conversations with them about the
importance of taking the Law of War into
account uh and that they in our
discussions with them uh we believe that
they are taking it into account but
again I'm not going to get into
individual specific strikes individual
specific actions the US House of
Representatives passed a bill to send
more than $14 billion to Israel but
because of how it's funded it won't pass
the Senate a small delay for Aid that is
wholly expected to be approved in the
coming weeks as the administration and
the US Congress sends the message with
words and deeds that it wholly sides
with Israel Patty khane Al jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer